Good morning John,
yes you got to record the
15th anniversary video of
vlogbrothers but I, and this
is a weird coincidence, one day
later get to record the 2,000th
vlogbrothers video on this
channel.
And I woke up yesterday
to a massive dump of snow
which meant that Orin’s school was canceled
So all of my normal plans
went right out the window.
So what do you get?
You get our
2000th video.
A compilation of clips
I recorded of me talking over it,
because I’m gonna be honest,
it’s one of the faster ways to
make a video.
I started out the
day making Orin a bagel and
then shoveling the walk even
though I knew dang well that
it wasn’t gonna stop snowing
for another 12 hours.
Then it was time for Katherine to take
over shoveling and I went
upstairs to write a couple of
really important emails and
oh my god is that really what
I look like?
Then Katherine
came in for some recovery time
and then it was time for a full hour
of Junk Yard Joust, a game where
you put hot wheels down a track
and they get eliminated if they
land on their back of their side.
Go ahead and pick which team
you think will win.
3 of them will,
because Orin doesn’t like it when
only one team wins.
I put the names of the teams in a pinned comment below.
You can reply
with the team that you like.
This is currently Orin’s #1 favorite
way to spend time, cars that get
eliminated go in this box.
He has
a bunch of very specific rules.
And then of course we had to
watch some actual Junkyard Joust
on Youtube.
Which is an amazing
Youtube channel if you haven’t
seen it.
It is so fun.
And then after
that he was sad that we weren’t
going to watch any more Youtube
videos so he decided to have a
rest underneath this pillow.
I then went for a walk to the
coffee shop to get Katherine a
latte and listen to the climax of
Jade Legacy which is a really amazing book.
And yes I did cry while walking down
the street.
Also on the way I helped push
a truck out of the snow.
I love a snowy walk.
I love a snowy town.
I love it when everything slows
down a little bit and everyone has
to take care of their stuff and take
care of each other.
I especially love
when there is a decaf americano
and a croissant at the end of it.
Then I had to start writing this script.
This is a video of me writing the words
I am saying right now, also not
tremendously flattering.
And then, time for more shoveling.
This time I did my neighbor’s walk because
he’s out of town and then I had to
tweet about how, because of a
scheduling mistake we had to
push the date of the Project for
Awesome back to February 25th
which I know is very inconvenient
for some people.
I’m sorry about this.
We tried to find some
other way to fix it but we failed.
But yes I am very excited for the
Project for Awesome, February 25th.
Everybody get ready. I also just
uploaded the amazing recap video that
Maia edited, and it’s on Hankschannel
and you can watch it and remember
all the fun times that we had.
Then I wrote some more emails and I wrote a
tweet about how my pants were wet
because of the truck that sprayed
snow all over me.
Then I recorded a secret video for somebody else that I can’t tell you about right now.
And I also wrote a bunch of other
stuff that I also can’t really tell you
about right now.
And look, one of the
really fantastic things about vlogbrothers
is that we often come to an important
point at the end of the video.
But often times, we don’t.
Sometimes life is just about life.
It’s about doing all the things you
wanted to do that day, or you needed
to do that day.
Sometimes it’s about
2,000 videos of content, 15 years of life
doing things that I couldn’t imagine
because they didn’t exist.
And always,
always, because a bunch of people
working together to keep each other
honest and push for really interesting
and useful stuff to exist in the world.
That stuff existed!
And the amazing
thing is, I have no idea if I’m halfway
through this.
Have I made most of the
videos I will ever make?
I don’t know.
Probably.
1,000 videos is a lot of videos.
But I don’t know.
I’m not looking too hard at it.
Because I certainly could not have guessed how the last 15 years would go.
What an amazing run! So weird! So much fun!
And so many amazing things that would
not have been possible without this
community or the people who work
at Complexly and at Vidcon and at DFTBA.
And finally, the moment you have
been waiting for: here are your
Junkyard Joust winners.
Congratulations to the white team,
the green team, and the batmobiles.
John, thank you and I will
see you on Tuesday.